what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
kingdom
1.2 really love the first episode
sincerely guys if you end up enjoying
our reaction it would mean the world if
you could go ahead and hit that like
button it helps us out in the algorithm
more than anything else please subscribe
click that notification about we're
going to be putting this out weekly i'm
just glad to have you here man some of
this korean cinema experience has been
freaking awesome it's something i wanted
to dive into years ago i remember
talking with john and my brother about
it this year has just been freaking
awesome to really be exploring it it's a
good year to be korean good year for to
be korean and like koreans
that's right bad here for races to hate
careers guys full length watch along as
we think about the time code or at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there we're at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
lastly thank you to prepper for editing
down these highlights for us let's get
into action people
[Music]
have
that's what i do john yeah
i just take things too seriously
done
oh yeah they never did get those beef
pancakes
do the zombies eat the insects too or
does the disease wipe out the insects
too neither seems possible
all the bugs are in that house
don't open dead inside
how unsettling where they all go they
can fly
i would draw your swords man
good thing you didn't have a storage
room
what someone like stuff them under there
no no
[Laughter]
it's like a king rat
what
uh
what oh look at that girl's neck
[Music]
yeah it's just so cool
like just when you thought they couldn't
brush up the zombie tropes
sorry
[Laughter]
oh
priorities man
[Music]
no no no
not in the water
[Music]
why not the water someone might drink
out of there
oh yeah that's true
all these bodies at the bottom of the
lake
[Laughter]
foreign
oh
they come alive at night or something or
like i don't know under rain or i'm
trying to think of any possibility
wow what a tracking shot no
like is this a crane is this a drone
guys no
listen for a second
oh was he trying to burn them all
probably i mean
yes yes
let it burn
[Laughter]
people won't need much convincing
grave
[Music]
does anybody have an iphone
there's a signal out here
oh there's gonna be like one left
oh no it'll be a dead horse dead horse
that's gonna come in the show i don't
like dead horses i like my horses living
and breathing
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] man
don't you got bigger fish to fry
yes
[Music]
good one man good one
oh
oh no
what the hell
so it is a nighttime thing
not easy i wonder why
because it's atmospheric
[Laughter]
you guys will be fine
what do you see
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
this office reaction
is that the dad
that's i think so
this is so messed up
[Applause]
yes we just need you to walk outside for
a minute
so people think you're alive put you on
a leash
you know
oh sick
[Music]
get those contortions going
why was he at the front of the line
[Applause]
oh no it's just this is just gonna get
really out of hand now yep
you guys got really lucky
[Laughter]
all you gotta do is hold these bars till
morning oh
no bad idea man
dude this thing
is awesome
who's who's in there
i'm not sure how long they waited open
this box
it's a really complicated vlog
can't kill a man with that sword
oh
was he was he bit couldn't tell
i think the guy on the ground was bit
oh yeah he's been he's he's gone for
well that sounds one problem yeah
[Music]
all the like yeah contortions and stuff
looks so nasty it's good physicality
turn around
[Laughter]
oh
nice
great splat
he's discovered the secret to beating
them yeah
he's like the first one
huh
that's
sound design
burn it all
let it burn
it's be an awesome video game yeah right
ghost of tsushima meets resident evil
that's literally way faster than i
expected it i thought it was gonna be
like since that's like episode four i
know
wow
yeah it's like each in these two
episodes you've seen like each little
wave of the infection as it's slowly
spreading i love i love just how
this show manages to progress quickly
with the plot
but also um
take its time
and
let you become absorbed into its
mood and atmosphere
i feel like the preferred way you got to
watch the show with headphones because
there's like subtle sounds
uh
and just the environments like when that
the place where the water is yeah where
i'm like oh you could hear some of the
wind and stuff in there that just
creates so much more of a mood and i i
feel like if you're not
watching this show with the headphones
you might miss some of that yeah yeah
absolutely the sound especially when
things are in different channels it
really enhances just the feeling that
you're there yeah yeah yeah i thought
this was gonna be like a few episodes
before we were feeling like our crown
prince was uh
was getting some validation and you know
right of his suspicions but this is so
how it's all just getting out it was
like yeah they have no reference point
for any of this so like they have no
idea what the hell's going on but i like
the inclusion of
what they're doing with uh
the the formation of or the the creation
of the zombies essentially yeah
uh like you're you're slowly
understanding the mythos behind it for
this specific series that they come out
at night
and
that they come from the resurrection i
mean that's i don't know that's not
confirmed yet but i'm assuming that's
what it's going to be that it stems from
the resurrection plant and i think they
just seamlessly weave the politics
together for it all i still don't
understand the point of keeping the
emperor alive it's just so that way like
when some people pass by they'd be like
no it's not moving
yeah
it's basically if they declare the
emperor's actually dead now then that
means the crown prince taking over yeah
so the whole point of just keeping him
in zombie form is for the few people who
can just confidently say no i saw him
moving yeah yeah he's making sounds he's
there he's still alive he's still he's
still moving and stuff so we're just
gonna we just gotta keep the body alive
for uh the the random witness who might
see him pass by or something like that
um but
as this is all falling apart like i
don't want to get caught up too much in
predictions just because like all the
episodes already out and we are watching
this just one week at a time so we'll
we'll see how this all unfolds
but from what we're getting so far i
mean i love the the main character i
love the the two of them the crown
prince lee and who who's the other guy
and uh mu young i think his name is yeah
i don't know how to pronounce it
properly yeah but uh though those two
characters just their chemistry together
real greg and john dynamic
constantly just in my buddy
hey
it's kind of funny but it's not funny
it's not pony man because you might
actually do it you never got me those
beef pancakes
yeah they're great together and like i i
love how seem it's interesting because
their relationship is both
friendly in a way and familial but also
based off of this hierarchy yeah you
know and and yeah in this hopeless
situation where even the crown prince is
sort of thrust out of his authority and
realm of comfort
they really do make a very natural pair
and i love watching the sort of progress
even when they're sort of separated and
i mean as the episode ended i feel like
the last time we saw him young was was
slipping into the crowd yeah so you know
i i have to imagine the way they get
reunited will probably be interesting to
see in the next couple of episodes and
i'm wondering i'm trying to ask myself
what is it of why i the guy who was part
of the i'm so sorry for not remembering
the name of locations and people's names
the
the person who they were searching for
and he came forward and was trying to
burn the bodies yeah yeah i find it
really interesting and i don't know
exactly what it is how this
from episode to episode it managed to
springboard me
into
being like this dude's kind of an
unlikable guy
too
i don't know why i really like this guy
please listen to this guy
it was his fault without him realizing
it was his fault what happened like he
did he didn't know
that you know serving i mean it was like
messed up and disgusting it's a
borderline sadistic i mean i granted
desperate times i get it yeah he had
good intent i get it
um and you know i i can never understand
such a poverty driven situation i mean i
will when the channel crashes and
youtube explodes then i'll know what
it's like to suffer
such
such depraved hunger
as you eat my lifeless mind
however i don't know maybe this is the
fact of how he was actually like really
capable in action yes you know how he
just like springboards past the guards
like throwing himself through it
he's past the guards
at all points he's able to fight off so
many of them yeah and then yeah like
knocking down the doors and such
and uh it it seemed like somehow what
this episode did for me with that
character
when you do an action like what he did
before because when he's serving all the
people in the last episode it sets you
up in a way of
oh look at this guy's actually as much
as he complains and [ __ ] he's actually a
good person you know and and of his
first scene he's you know going up
against the the king and and he's you
know
standing up for the people and as much
as
there were decisions that he was making
that were like man you're making this
guy kind of unlikable he feels very
human in in that regard so but then it's
like oh man but you've been if you had
all the people human being what's wrong
it's disgusting
but i think what this episode
i guess what they made the line very
clear on is that he really
cares though yeah yeah at the end of the
day despite some of the things he says
and choices he makes he really cares
like he was like desperate as hell to
try to get through to people like i know
everyone's gonna try to kill me i'm the
guy you're looking for let me just burn
these bodies please let me know hey i'm
gonna fight you all there's no time yeah
so i think that's that's that might be
what it is because uh i was kind of
surprised by how much i was really
loving watching him on screen this
episode yeah it's not like the focal
point of this episode there is
he's part of the focus um but that that
was probably that surprised me most i
was
i was pretty surprised that the guy who
um was antagon the only person's name i
know it was lee chang is crowded
but the way how
uh
the person who was antagonizing him um
you know the one who keeps like
obviously wanting to kill him yeah and
you know uh pretty much
rob him of his
uh
really his pedigree his prestige yeah
the one is really carrying that torch
for you're causing treason
yeah yeah even though you know he know
he knows he's not yeah but he just wants
to bring him down out of how jealous he
is and
such the
point
being is i was surprised by how oh wow
the second episode he turns i thought
that was gonna be like a thing that goes
on for a while just because i'm used
that's what american dramas you
definitely do
yeah i think that's what's been
refreshing about watching a lot of this
is it's not as predictable and i don't
know if it's just the fact that it's
korean drama
um
or if it's just
generally just really great writing yeah
it's probably both yeah and i mean even
just from like a zombie story
perspective i think they've done a
really s a neat job in how they're
spreading things out because i feel like
a lot of zombie things do the outbreak
you know in interesting ways but
oftentimes i feel like part of the
driving sort of aesthetic force is that
oh man like there's no way to stop the
spread whereas this is like a very slow
set of waves and it's like you have you
know that first bunch of corpses and
they're all sort of isolated and you're
like man
if he'd just gotten back and was able to
burn all this down
maybe there wouldn't be an outbreak
but because of yeah these decisions that
uh overlap into yeah political greed and
you know treasonous uh pursuits and
whatnot it becomes this yeah what feels
like a very big and intricate and
interworking you know series of
decisions that are just gonna make this
that much worse because nobody
understands and it's it's a great
tension driver that fills me with that
like nervous laughter of like man
these people
don't understand and are just like not
paying any mind to uh yeah any of the
warnings they're given in any way shape
or form and then to watch as like you
know even the magistrate is sitting
there like well go on
poke the body
like the second something turns you know
they are still kind of like frightened
by it so yeah i like the human elements
of how they're building the outbreak i
like the sort of way they're spreading
that out because it does feel more akin
to this time where i don't know i feel
like in in a in like the 16th century or
something like that things wouldn't
spread in the same way they do now
and yeah i think they've done a nice job
with also just displacing the drama and
the zombie stuff because you know in the
first i feel like the first halves of
both of these episodes have laced in
your different clues and your different
things that you know are gonna come back
and get more sinister later like you
know dumping bodies in the river or
whatever but then as the second half of
each episode at least these first two
has kicked in that's when you really
start to get to you know the physical
matter at hand which is the outbreak
yeah and so yeah i think they've done a
nice job of just balancing both making
both sets intriguing mixing the you know
character and political motivations into
the mess messiness of the action that
goes down when zombies show up yeah and
yeah the way they portray them all is
like
that way they pull them out from
underneath it's that we've seen more and
more in recent years of you know zombies
being portrayed as like roaches just
like crawling all over each other and
piles and stacks and whatnot and to see
just like an interconnected chain of
bodies pulled out like it was a really
unique image even out of all the you
know millions of zombie movies that i've
been subject to i was like wow i've
never quite seen that take before well
there were parts of it that were a
little confusing at the time because you
were like are they dead are they asleep
yeah are they just human bodies who were
did they who placed these bodies so like
it wasn't clear-cut and i think to your
point about the way this collapse is
ultimately progressing
what makes it
very different
is a lot of the things that of how how
[ __ ] could be prevented
are often
consequences of people having
good intentions
like
okay the king's dead how do we help him
out uh
yeah know well
it's both though because it's how do we
help them out but also how do we usurp
the throne like how do we keep them
alive in order to yeah pursue our own
goal but that's one part it's also yes
it's both at the same time though
take what you were saying about the one
guy who wanted to burn the bodies the
crown prince
if the crown prince wasn't so intent on
discovering the truth so them getting
inside the gates
that guy could have successfully burned
the bodies yeah you know yeah that's a
good call too
um
so that like everyone has good
intentions
they just don't understand what's going
on yeah you can't see the big picture so
some of these guys just like kind of
slowed down a little bit
thought it's gonna have been prevented
yeah
um which
like the guy
or the guy who was just talking about of
how i grew to really like him in this
episode good intentions he wanted to
help out the people and as much as
there's messed up things about how he
did it his intentions were good
was serving his people
help saving everyone's ass
and now his uh so yeah it is interesting
to see that they're not like suffering
consequences off of like terrible
choices
it's actually all good choices so it
seems like this is all inevitable
yeah it's it's a fascinating way they've
they've put those two flavors together
because there are aspects where you're
like oh this this could be prevented but
also yeah given the limited scope and
the fact that you're in a much earlier
time where there's not a lot of
precedent for even the fictional lore of
this
yeah it does feel like this inevitable
thing that is naturally occurring even
through just people's best intentions
yeah
yeah and again i mean i feel like
this is a point that will probably just
get reiterated all the time so i'm not
gonna i'll just say it again that's for
the sake of saying it that the way this
show is captured is undeniably cinematic
it doesn't feel like you're watching a
show
uh the way they hand like their whoever
their look whoever is their a.d or their
location scouts phenomenal that's why i
was like it was so
it seems such a part of
the the dna of the story that i'm like
do they
write
around locations you know like that it
just kind of popped into my mind because
yeah they the amount of tracking shots
they use to really let you get a sense
of the environment like it doesn't feel
like you're on sets at all it feels like
real locations whether that's the
wilderness
trekking through the woods going through
the forest uh
it's just any of the many places you're
looking through without and throughout
the kingdom
like all the area like even because you
can build pretty elaborate sets but they
don't always roof that stuff and that
one where you're like tracking above
this entire structure like and how it's
near the river and all those those
beautiful gorgeous trees it's it's
surprising just how
grand this all looks it's very rich in
in its color and texture so
yeah i'm very much uh very much
impressed with this this is uh this is
this is a really it's like cool too this
is like a cool show everything it's just
cool like it's like intimate but also
kind of huge and also cool but also very
suspenseful and personal and yeah
i'm i'm pleasant i i'm liking this a lot
more than i expected to i mean i
expected to like it just because of the
amount of people that recommended it
uh but i wasn't expected to be like damn
this show is really good doing it for me
yeah
quality
right here yeah yeah
um all right guys this is satisfying
keep a lookout for our reactions to the
next one
uh episode three because yeah we're
gonna we're gonna be we're committed
we're committed
see you guys soon thanks for being here